le début de la guerre en Ukraine les
européens ont adopté 5 séries de
sanctions la sixième salle vise le
pétrole russe la Commission propose un
embargo dans 6 mois c'est non dit la
Hongrie qui refuse la proposition à
l'état bonjour Alix le bourdon vous
retrouve à Bruxelles l'opposition
hongroise était attendue
en effet on s'était à craindre de la
part de la Hongrie qui avait déjà
prévenu en début de semaine quelle
opposerait son veto à toute proposition
d'embargo sur le gaz ou le pétrole russe
alors je vous rappelle que la dépendance
au pétrole russe est très inégal selon
les pays européens elle s'élève à plus
de 75% pour la Hongrie mais à moins de
25% pour des pays comme la France et
l'Espagne l'Allemagne qui au départ
était dépendante à 35% du pétrole russe
c'était un temps opposé à cette
proposition d'embargo sur le pétrole
russe mais elle a récemment levé ses
réserves puisqu'elle a réussi à réduire
sa dépendance mais ça c'est beaucoup
plus difficile à faire pour des pays
comme la Hongrie et la Slovaquie qui
sont enclavés et qui n'ont accès qu'un
oléoduc russe alors là proposition de la
Commission européenne aujourd'hui
prévoit un arrêt progressif des achats
européens de pétrole russe d'ici la fin
de l'année mais justement elle prévoit
aussi des exemptions pour ces deux pays
la Hongrie et la Slovaquie qui pourront
continuer à acheter du pétrole russe
durant l'année 2023 mais visiblement ça
n'est pas suffisant pour le gouvernement
hongrois qui estime que la proposition
de la Commission européenne et bien ne
garantit pas la sécurité énergétique du
pays le problème c'est que cette
proposition doit être validée par les 27
États membres et qu'elle requiert
l'unanimité pour entrer en vigueur merci
beaucoup pour ces explications à l'ex le
Bourdon et puis Kiev vient de réagir
l'indé ministre Ukrainiens affirme que
ce refus fait de la Hongrie je cite une
complice de crimes de guerre